[Music]  Joanna Gaines shares the secret to  getting her newborn son to sleep the mom  of five took to her Instagram stories  with this sweet video of little crew  asleep in her arms proving the key to a  successful snooze is a stroll through  the family garden she also went on to  post a number of impressive snaps of the  home she shares with hubby chip Gaines  before instagramming this a precious  close-up of her baby boy fast asleep  Chip and Joanna welcomed crew on June  21st  they share five kiddos together  including eight-year-old em EK 9 year  old duke 11 year old ella and 13 year  old drake they just grow up so fast  last week joanna shared this sweet photo  of her hgtv hubby holding little crew  along with the caption chip started a  tradition with drake where he wore the  hospital bracelet until it fell off  looks like the tradition lives on  hashtag 5  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]